so hopefully you had a nice safe holiday  wanted to share some a great video drone  video from rory gregorio and check this  out so rory sent his drone up last night  and swinging around what it looks like  from the southwest valley looking across  all across town and check out all of the  fireworks that were going off not only  along the strip but also in different  neighborhoods across the valley all at  the same time and of course there were  only a few sanctioned firework displays  from  hotel properties but the ones in the  neighborhoods that were all shooting off  simultaneously those were not the legal  fireworks but there were still plenty of  them shooting off so fantastic video  thank you roy for sending that in and  sharing that with us